good evening
i'm perd hapley you may know me from the
television shows i appear on
including you heard with perd starring
me perdhapley
channel 4 news with perd hapley and the
final word with perd
starring me once again perd happily
the story of the thing you're about to
watch is soon you'll be seeing it
and the it is the gag and blooper reel
from the television
show parks and recreation starring perd
hapley
the story of this camera is that it's
shooting me from a different angle
and now i'm going to present to you the
thing i'm about to introduce
so sit back relax recline and
calm down but most importantly i want
you to enjoy the parks and recreation
season four gag reel which promises to
be
hilarious and the only reason i'm
laughing is because
it's on the cue card enjoy
andrew i need evidence got it wait you
don't know what evidence ah right on
yes hit me next to my desk is a picture
of a female politician bella abzug is
that scary face funny hat gap tooth or
bill clinton's wife funny hat
funny hat on the back of it is a key
taped to it and then that opens my
bottom drawer and my desk
[Laughter]
gets
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's funny okay okay
season four everybody i don't care if
you're poison in my campaign this team
has tons of heart and zero know-how
you're the only one sorry
i'm sorry
hey how was the rally nailed it no
we didn't no we didn't
no we didn't no and i'm in love with you
because you're just like me you're a dog
date me ann i'm single
[Laughter]
ron you're gonna construct the stage yes
ma'am i really think we should try and
involve this talking dog
and will you go out on a date with me
you're the prettiest dog i've ever seen
ham remember when we had sex in the
gutter
on rodney street i'll never forget her
dad
i'm gonna come over there and [ __ ] you
up
[Laughter]
i'm gonna go to the bathroom and powder
my nose amongst other things
if you know what i mean
dude is she gonna powder her vagina
i'm sorry dude is she going to powder
[Laughter]
can we just get it on the next steak
yeah yeah okay okay okay
[Laughter]
i just need one second might be pollen
yes wearing off
sir i had to run away
i literally had to run you apologize yes
and then
we leak the details to the press which
restores your reputation and buys us
enough time to finish the bus tour
nice nice the machine
sorry the door's closing on tweet
[Laughter]
okay well we just have to work harder i
mean good news is we can call it a night
and get a super early start on our
door-to-door tomorrow
he's like are they gonna let me go with
that
okay well we just have to work hard
well we just have to work harder i mean
good news
all right all right
first struck a walk in it's gone
factory explosion and nobody died
[Music]
i'm sorry this is totally unprofessional
let's just keep going and we'll come
back to it
[Laughter]
what was funny about the last thing was
that the people didn't say what they
were supposed to
for more hilarious moments keep your
eyes focused on the screen
and your ears listening for the sound
that is occurring in the room
coming this fall a new series on nbc
amy poehler adam scott
catherine han rashida jones
and introducing paul rudd that hurt my
feelings
billy justice without them
there is no justice leslie knope
wants all these adorable puppies and
kittens to
die please miss
nope please don't turn me into a fur
coat
vote for bobby newport he likes his
puppies
alive vo bobby newport for city council
and now back to more parks and
[Music]
recreation
sorry wait i thought i put it in park
and does this help this helps a lot
it's hard right mm-hmm things are gonna
get
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's like being left alone in a room
with two cameras and little people
things are gonna get better right
who my name is annabelle vandercrank
from the
memphis vandercranks and i just about
lose
my head when the sun falls down
on my mustache
i'm sorry i need my mustache glued
listen it was very cool if you'd asked
me to come here i'm uh
i'm excited yeah we are too so let's get
this straight away going
and go ahead
[ __ ] my pants on camera check
i have hot snakes you guys what's hot
snakes
it's when the diarrhea comes out like a
hot snake candy
i get hot snakes in bubble gut
you know what's crazy is i there i
definitely
like a poop i just put my pants
not full i'm not a full turd but enough
you